[Música]
Este martes llega a territorio
estadounidense el presidente francés
Emmanuel el mandatario tendrá un
encuentro con Joe biden y también con
empresarios y organizaciones entre los
temas de discusión se encuentran en el
ámbito espacial y las relaciones
económicas entre ambas naciones
patreon donde declarado supremacista y
autor confeso del tiroteo que tuvo lugar
en mayo pasado en la ciudad
estadounidense de Búfalo Se declaró
culpable de asesinato en primer grado y
de otros cargos estatales por lo que
podría enfrentar cadena perpetua
Este martes se juega la jornada número
10 del mundial de Qatar los ojos de
América Latina se posan sobre Ecuador
que se enfrenta senegal por el grupo a
otro partido que centra la atención es
el de Irán y Estados Unidos una
rivalidad política que ha llegado hasta
el fútbol
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano y del mundial soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos hablando del
presidente francés Emanuel maccón que
hará una visita de estado a Estados
Unidos desde el martes en la noche hasta
el viernes entre los temas más
importantes previstos para discutir está
en el ámbito espacial las relaciones
económicas y la francofonía Gabriel
colchón nos cuenta más
una invitación que es señal de buen
momento entre ambas naciones Emmanuel
Llegará el martes por la noche a
Washington para un viaje de tres días
con mucha pompa Esta visita es la
segunda invitación que recibe desde 2018
cuando lo invitó Donald Trump esta será
la primera visita de estado de la
Administración biden Harris pondrá de
relieve la profunda y duradera relación
entre Estados Unidos y Francia nuestro
más antiguo Aliado que se basa en los
valores democráticos que compartimos los
vínculos económicos y la cooperación en
materia de defensa y seguridad la
cuestión económica estará en el centro
de las conversaciones la ley de
reducción de la inflación firmada por el
presidente biden preocupa a Europa que
denuncia el proteccionismo
estadounidense parece esperar limitar
las medidas destinadas a repatriar a
Estados Unidos las inversiones
industriales vinculadas con la
transición energética los temas
espaciales
similares también serán tratados la
última etapa del viaje será Nueva
Orleans la ciudad fundada por el francés
donde se hablara de la francofonía el
encuentro diplomático también contará
con una escena de estado de centenas de
personas en la cual participará la
delegación francesa compuesta por varios
ministros parlamentarios y
personalidades además de una acogida muy
especial se espera de este viaje que
Emanuel McQueen pueda hablar en nombre
de toda la Unión Europea
el servicio geológico de Estados Unidos
informó que élma una loa el volcán
activo más grande del mundo entró en
erupción en Hawaii aunque los
científicos se mantienen a la espera no
creen que pueda poner en riesgo a la
población ampliamos los detalles en el
informe
el cielo se tornó rojo en Hawaii
mientras cenizas y escombros salían a la
superficie un hecho histórico el mauna
loa entró en erupción es el volcán más
grande en activo y llevaba dormido desde
1984 su periodo de calma más largo desde
que hay registros aunque no ha habido
evacuaciones los científicos son
prudentes no queremos intentar adivinar
el volcán tenemos que dejar que
realmente nos muestre lo que va a hacer
y luego informaremos a la gente de lo
que está sucediendo lo antes posible por
el momento se han abierto dos refugios
como medida de precaución pero no se
cree que haya peligro ni para locales ni
para turistas puesto que la mitad de las
erupciones registradas se limitaron a la
Cumbre sin embargo se está actuando con
prevención ya saben estamos muy
atrasados bueno estábamos muy atrasados
para una erupción del mauna loa y por
eso nos hemos estado preparando
el mauna loa es uno de los cinco
volcanes que forman la isla de Hawai
Ojalá es el único considerado inactivo
son conocidos por su gran tamaño mauna
loa mide 4.169 metros
[Música]
se han producido estos volcanes muy
grandes y anchos que se conocen como
volcanes escudo y eso se debe a que la
composición del magma que entra en
erupción allí es muy fluido
desde hace unas semanas se han activado
las alarmas después de una serie de
temblores algunos ciudadanos están
tomando medidas de prevención pero
acostumbrados a vivir bajo amenaza
aceptan que la diosa de los volcanes
pele fluirá donde y cuando quiera
El joven acusado de haber matado a 10
afroamericanos en un supermercado de la
ciudad estadounidense de Búfalo en el
estado de Nueva York Se declaró culpable
de asesinatos racistas y actos de
terrorismo su juicio está previsto para
febrero y se enfrenta la cadena perpetua
y hasta la prenda hasta la pena de
muerte Gabriel tiene los detalles
este lunes el joven acusado de haber
llevado a cabo la matanza en un
supermercado de la Ciudad de Búfalo se
ha declarado culpable el 14 de mayo
asesinó a 10 personas afroe
estadounidenses un acto calificado de
racista y terrorista
nuestro cliente se ha declarado culpable
de todos los cargos Sabiendo
perfectamente que pasará el resto de su
vida en prisión
las autoridades dicen que el autor
confesó de 19 años buscaba
específicamente matar a personas afroe
estadounidenses cuando abrió Fuego en la
tienda según Los investigadores el
atacante público en internet antes del
tiroteo un discurso racista en el que se
declaraba Suprema si está blanco y
prometía matar a afroamericanos
investigó y se dirigió específicamente a
la tienda Tops de la avenida Jefferson
por su ubicación incluso llegó a ser una
búsqueda de Google del código postal del
estado de Nueva York que tenía tiene
mayor concentración de afroamericanos
este masacre tuvo lugar solo 10 días
después de otra matanza perpetrada por
un joven de 18 años que mató a 19 niños
y dos profesores en una escuela de en
Texas desde entonces han aumentado el
número de tiroteos masivos alimentando
la frustración de los estadounidenses
frente a la falta de solución respecto a
la multiplicación de matanzas el
presidente demócrata dubaidane todavía
no ha conseguido impulsar en el congreso
la prohibición de los fusiles de asalto
debido a la oposición republicana en
Chile Pese a que el gobierno de Gabriel
borich llegó a un acuerdo con parte de
Los camioneros que protestan dos
organizaciones mantienen la huelga que
ella cumple ocho días consecutivos los
involucrados aseguran en que en el pacto
con El Ejecutivo no se estipula una
disminución en los precios de los
combustibles algo que era la principal
demanda de los manifestantes previamente
Patricia Luna corresponsal de France 24
en Santiago nos explicó las
implicaciones económicas de este paro
son muchos los sectores afectados en el
fantasma de los abastecimiento planea
sobre chiles desde hace varios días
debido a la naturaleza angosta del país
que hace que mucho el transporte el 95%
de los bienes se transportan por
carretera no solo alimentación sino
también material de la construcción
maquinarias gasol y otro afectado
especialmente al sector de agrícola de
la fruta que comienza su temporada
especialmente la exportación de cerezas
evaluaban en 500 millones de dólares
semanales las pérdidas y el paro
continuaba también a otros sectores como
el sector forestal a la carne y también
al precio y el bolsillo de los chilenos
que veían como subían al haber una mayor
escasez sobre todo las hortalizas al ir
a comprar en un de fuerte inflación
Hablamos ahora del mundial de Qatar en
el décimo día se definen los
clasificados por los grupos a y b
América Latina centra su atención en
Ecuador que se enfrenta a senegal por el
grupo a los ojos del Norte del
continente estarán sobre el encuentro
entre Irán y Estados Unidos por el grupo
B Natalia Ruiz enviada especial de
France 24 nos amplió los detalles de la
jornada número 9 que se vivió este lunes
esta segunda jornada de la fase de
grupos nos ha dejado dos nuevas
elecciones clasificadas a octavos de
final aquí en Qatar 2022 Por una parte
Brasil por el grupo G mientras que
Portugal logra pasar a la siguiente
ronda por el grupo H Brasil venció por
la mínima diferencia a la selección de
Suiza gracias a un gol de casemiro
mientras que Portugal ganó por un
doblete de Bruno Fernández y nada menos
que Uruguay En todo caso antes en más
temprano el día de hoy Camerún se
enfrentó a hacer bien uno de los dos
partidos más espectaculares del día de
hoy partido que terminó en empate 13 por
3 pero las dos selecciones pues se ponen
en aprietos con este resultado la
próxima fecha Camerún se enfrentará a
Brasil mientras que Serbia lo hará ante
suiza en cuanto al grupo H pues la
selesaba como ya les venía diciendo
logró esta Victoria ante los charrúas
que salió muy prudente a ese terreno de
juego y tendrán que enfrentarse a ghana
las estrellas a negras que ganaron otro
de los partidos más lo del día de hoy
una victoria de tres goles por dos ante
Corea del Sur La que sí los va a tener
bastante difícil será precisamente esta
selección asiática que tendrá Sí o sí
que salirle a ganar a Portugal los
partidos de estos grupos se disputarán
el próximo viernes es todo por el
momento en francés 24 continúan con
nosotros
[Música]